Arquímides se está vaciando a su tina de baño.
Por cada 2 minutos que pasan,
se drenan 7 galones de agua.
¿Cuál de las siguientes funciones puede representar
la cantidad de galones de agua en la tina "A",
como función
de los minutos que han transcurrido, "T"?
y nos dan estas opciones de aquí,
así que bien, empecemos...
empecemos haciendo una pequeña gráfica.
Ya está mi eje,
que va a ser mi eje del agua
y voy a poner por acá mi eje del tiempo...
ya está mi eje del tiempo.
Bien, la tina comienza con
alguna cantidad de agua que no me especifican,
pero tengo que asumir
que esa cantidad es positiva, así que,
voy a llamar a esa cantidad A0,
así que A0 es
galones iniciales de agua...
galones...
Iniciales...
de agua...
de agua.
Esa es la cantidad de agua
con la que empieza la tina,
y si yo dejo pasar 2 minutos,
de hecho el tiempo está medido en minutos...
minutos...
y el agua,
la cantidad de agua esta medida en galones...
galones...
Solo para tener nuestras unidades claras,
entonces yo sé que si dejó pasar 2 minutos,
de que se empieza a vaciar la tina,
entonces aquí tengo 1 minuto
y por acá tendría 2 minutos...
1, 2...
Entonces,
no sé dónde estaré
porque no sé con cuánta agua empecé pero sé que se habrán perdido 7 galones de agua,
así que digamos,
si aquí estoy en 2,
entonces este punto aquí,
tendría altura A0 menos 7,
de modo que la gráfica,
de cómo se va a drenando el agua,
si supongo que se drena de un modo constante,
se ve algo así,
donde la idea es que,
eso fuera una línea recta que pasa por el punto,
que está en 0,0 y por el punto 2,A0-7.
Bien, entonces esa es la gráfica
de cómo se va vaciando la tina,
Ahora, para poder escribir una función que describa cómo se va vaciando la tina,
una buena idea sería considerar
la tasa de cambio de esta gráfica.
Lo que significa eso,
es que tanto está cambiando el eje vertical
por un cambio en el eje horizontal.
Que tanto cambia la cantidad de agua dependiendo
de la cantidad del tiempo
y eso frecuentemente se conoce
como la pendiente de esta línea recta,
entonces, vamos a escribir esto
el cambio, la tasa de cambio,
del agua entre el tiempo,
puede escribir este triangulito que es la letra griega,
delta mayúscula y significa cambio en.
Así que el cambio en la cantidad de agua
dividido entre el cambio...
el cambio en la cantidad de tiempo.
Bien, entonces, yo sé que si el tiempo cambia en dos unidades
si pasa que empieza a vaciarse el agua a 2 minutos,
si en la cantidad del tiempo
cambian dos unidades,
entonces la cantidad de agua
cambia en -7 unidades
porque estoy perdiendo agua,
por lo tanto el cambio es negativo
estoy perdiendo agua.
Y entonces, el cambio en "A" entre el cambio en "t"
es igual a -7 medios.
Les recuerdo, esto generalmente se conoce
como la pendiente de esta recta
y eso ya me permite escribir una ecuación general.
¿Por qué?
porque ya que tengo esto,
lo que puedo hacer es decir, bueno,
quiero averiguar la cantidad de agua
en algún tiempo "t"
pues empecé con una cantidad de agua A0
y luego por cada minuto que pasa,
tenía que sumar menos siete medios
por la cantidad de tiempo
ese es el cambio que está teniendo.
Pero como estoy sumando menos siete medios
es lo mismo que escribir menos....
vamos a ponerlo con otro color...
menos siete medios,
de el tiempo por cada minuto que pase,
por cada 2 minutos que pasen,
yo pierdo siete galones,
o por cada minuto que pase
yo pierdo siete medios galones.
Bien, entonces, tengo esta ecuación de aquí
y si ustedes recuerdan
la forma de las ecuaciones punto pendiente,
quizás recuerden que una ecuación es de la forma
"y" es igual a "mx" + "b"
y que esto describe una recta con pendiente "m"
e intersección con el eje "y" "b",
pero en este caso no tengo "y" ni eje "x"
tengo eje "a" y "T",
eje vertical y eje horizontal,
por lo tanto esta ecuación se escribiría como "A"
la cantidad de agua es igual
a la pendiente de la recta que es menos siete medios,
observen que es una recta que tiene pendiente negativa, es una función decreciente
más...
perdón, por el tiempo,
el tiempo es la variable independiente en este caso,
más la intersección con el eje vertical que sería A0.
Es importante señalar que esto solo funcionó porque la tina siempre se drena a la misma velocidad.
Siempre se drenan 7 galones de agua
por cada 2 minutos que pasan.
Si esa tasa cambiará,
si este número de aquí no fuera una constante,
no podría describir esto con una línea recta
pero bueno,
si comparo las ecuaciones,
las respuestas que me dan
con esta forma de la ecuación
entonces notó que la única
que tiene la forma correcta es esta de aquí,
por lo tanto,
yo creo que esa es la respuesta correcta.
De hecho puede descartar las demás
sin tener que haber hecho todo esto,
por ejemplo, la primera respuesta,
cuando "T" vale 0, "A" vale 0 también,
y entonces me describe una tina que está vacía en el primer instante,
pero para que vaciaría Arquímides su tina,
si de por si ya estaba vacía,
por lo tanto eso no tiene sentido.
Por otro lado,
esta ecuación a pesar de que cuando "T" vale 0,
la tina sí tendría 100 galones de agua
me describe una tina que se está llenando.
Esta es una pendiente positiva,
por lo tanto sería una línea que se vería algo así,
y es una tina que se va llenando,
conforme pasa el tiempo,
hay más y más agua en la tina,
por lo tanto ésta tampoco sirve.
Esta es la opción que tenía,
y ésta
que me describe,
pues de nuevo, me describe una tina que tiene
20 galones cuando "T" vale 0 ,
pero de nuevo,
se están aumentando la cantidad de galones
y de hecho está pendiente ni siquiera tiene algo que ver con la pendiente que tenía
por lo tanto,
esta ecuación tampoco puede ser.
Así que la única función que puede representar la cantidad de galones de agua en la tina
como una función
de los minutos que han transcurrido es,
esta función de aquí precisamente.